[موسيقى]
مرحبا اقبال كبير يشهد فيلم افاتار على
الشباك السينمائي في السعوديه مصر وكافه
انحاء الوطن العربي وطبعا العالم حيث سبق
العرض الجماهير للفيل معارض خاص في مصر
بحضور النخبه من النجوم اللي عبروا عن
سعادتهم انطلاقه العرض العربيه من القاهره
حيث يعود المخرج الشهيد جيمس كاميرون
وعشاق السينما الى عالم السينما من الحميه
والخيال اذا بدات تصوير عام 2017 ويعرض
هذا الجزء من الفيلم بعد 13 سنه من عرض
الجزء الاول بالسينمات واللي يحقق ارقام
قياسيه على الشباك حول العالم تجاوزت
مليارين الدولار ليصبح حاليا اكثر الافلام
دخله في تاريخ السينما متعديا بذلك في نفس
المخرج تايتنك واللي تصدق قائمه الشباك
الاكل
لمده 13 سنه
كبير جدا
في العالم وفي الشرق الاوسط وفي كل حته
وبعدين ده مش جديد على جيمس كاميرون
كانخرجي يعني انا بحب اعمله حتى من قبل
افاتار يعني
13 سنه مستنيين يعني كثير رقم كبير جدا
يعني
اعتقد ان شاء الله هيكون كبير جدا الفيلم
ده يعني
للشباب كمان اكثر فاعتقد انه ما لوش نوعيه
محدده يعني هو فيلم للجمهور العام وافلام
جينز كامل عامه كلها كانت مشهوره بانها كل
الاعمار بتخشها يعني هي افلام ممتعه وفيها
مغامره
اكشن فهو اعتقد هو هيبقى كذاب لكل الاعمار
شكل جديد في عالم الجرافيكس والسي جي اي
اللي مبني اللي هم اصلا
بشكل عام دلوقت همم حاسس انه هيبقى في
موحه حكايه العالم
له دراسه كبيره جدا نزله غواصه مخصوص وقعد
يدرس تحت الميه العالم ده
والحاجات اللي فيها خيال بشكل عام اييه ما
بقتش معموله للاطفال يعني يعني
فاتمنى ان الجزء الاول انا حاسس ان هو
كمان يعني ااا هيكون احلى الجزء الثاني
حاسس ان هيكون احلى من بوز الاول
[موسيقى]
في مقدمتهم النجم محمد هنادي بخير نبيل
الجميل اختصاصي تجميل الى جانب رامز جلال
بفيلم اخي فوق الشجره وكريم محمود عبد
العزيز بفيلم شلبي بينما يغرد فيه جروب مع
ميسي في بطوله نسائيه لروبي يسرى اللوزي
ودارين حداد في نفس السنه بالاضافه اللي
في فيلم المطاريد لاحمد حاتم واياد حيث
ياتي هذا الموسم بعد فتره ركود اخيره
يعيشها الشباك من اسابيع تزامنا مع
الاهتمام العالمي ببطوله كاس العالم 22
والانتهات على احد الماضي
[موسيقى]
اخترت مجله زراعيه الامريكيه العالميه في
عددها الاخيره المسلسل المصري البحث عن
علا ضمن قائمتها لافضل الاعمال العالميه
اللي تم عرضها عبر المنصات خلال عام 2002
و 2020 حيث وضعت المجله العالميه المسلسل
في المرتبه الثالثه ضمن هذه الاعمال وهو
طبعا العمل العربي الوحيد اللي دخل هذه
القائمه في انجاز كبير مسلسل البحث العلمي
من بطوله النجمه هند صبري واللي شاركت فيه
كمنتج منفذ لاول مره ومستوحه من شخصيات من
تاليف غاده عبد العال وقصه وسناريو وحوار
مع الوزير وغاده عبد العال ومن اخراج هذه
البلدي
مود الاعلان على الانتهاء من كتاب
السيناري الجزء الثاني من فيلم حريم كريم
مقرر انه يحمل اسم اولاد حريم كريم وهناك
تساؤلات كثيره عن الجزء الملحق والفيلم
الناجح وين راح يكون مكمل ام مستقل تماما
باستثناء الاسم الناجح والرغبه في
استثماره الجماهير حريم كريم عام 2005 وضم
مجموعه كبيره من النجوم بينهم مصطفى قمر
الياسمين عبد العزيز داليا البحيري ريهام
عبد الغفور بس مع علا غانم وطلعت زكريا
وغيرهم ومن المفترض كمان انه يضم هذا جزء
النجوم كمان تاتي الاحداث الزمنيه للجزء
الملحق بعد 22 سنه من الجزائر
نحن نشوف قصه الاولاد بقى مش مش بس
الاستمراريه بتاعه الجزء الاول ف همم طبعا
مش كل الافلام الجزء الثاني بتنجح حتى هو
يعني ولكن احنا لازم نفضل نجرب ونحاول
وانا نجتهد ونشتغل بضمير وان شاء الله
نوايانا الطيبه توصل للجمهور مين من
البطلات ما هتكون موجوده
مين البطله الفيلم كريم
[موسيقى]
في دبي بمناسبه قبل عام الجديد استضافه في
ابرز نجوم التطبيق اللي كرمت اصحاب
المحتوى الابراج بينهم
التشجيع لاصحاب المحتوى الاكثر انتشارا
للتنافس على المحتوى الافضل وتحقيق اهداف
طموحه حيث اصبح تيك توك الاكثر انتشارا
حاليا بشكل لا يصدق وتخطى كونه تطبيق
فيديو قصير شبكه اجتماعيه عاديه وبعد ما
كان هدفه التغلب على منافسين اصبح محرك
بحث يتم الاعتماد عليه من قبل الجميع حيث
يعتبر البعض منصه الاحلام اللي ممكن انها
تحول اي موهبه من اي نوع الى ترانس
[موسيقى]